let's talk about something else because
Luis is boring Planned Parenthood has
now started this campaign I defy for
people who don't know Planned Parenthood
now when I saw this I did do a
double-take I thought it was MTV I
thought it was Vox because it's like I
don't know if there's like a final cut
or an avid for social justice warrior
editing software there's a plugin but
it's the exact same as like that
flash-forward Saturday morning cartoon
or like McGee and me cartoon sort of
writing combined with real life so they
sort of i defy and the whole idea is i
defy your social norms i defy your
labels and something about abortion and
they're somewhere they did three videos
let's get into them you probably do i
don't know what's the procedure for
insufferable [ __ ] they're still
working on that doesn't come around with
a fry solution can't believe they got
the seedless watermelon before that i
know first up they say procedure right
procedure this is a procedure let's
remove what it is abortion and this is
an argument the left uses all the time
well if you knew someone that way morgan
freeman did this with islam we'll talk
about that later well if you knew a
muslim that wouldn't be the case well if
you knew a black person you wouldn't
feel that way well if you knew someone
had an abortion you wouldn't an end it
by the way if you say well if you knew a
black person you say but well actually
but my half-brother is black oh you like
that defends you look i have a black
friend you just set it up so no matter
what someone says it can't be legitimate
this is a social justice warrior way as
we talked about with Reza Aslan now that
can kind of work I understand for
example I'm a fan of mixed martial arts
and a lot of people go that's a blood
spread meryl streep
it's a blood sport it's Hort but will
actually hold on these are the rules and
you explain it to them this this is why
it matters a lot of wrestlers from
colleges and opportunity to make a
living oh okay i didn't understand that
or if you knew someone maybe uh paints
that you think paintball is silly well
maybe if you knew someone well paintball
is a great team-building experience and
oh you know okay Eckener
I know you you play paint I have a
different perception it's not the same
with murder that doesn't change the root
cause of this right the problem with
people who are who are against abortion
believe that it is murder so it's like
saying well if you knew a pedophile like
yo John you see you like little kids
yeah I can't get I scroll all the time
you your school kid you screwed for kids
what is just small world
ah you know I guess I guess I had a
wrong perception of pedophiles who screw
kids John I know I know we get a bad rap
that doesn't happen you can't apply it
to something that involves morals and
ethics to a deeply deeply rooted issue
it just it just doesn't apply it's not
like a hobby it's not like a haircut
it's not like facial piercings it's not
like taste in music they apply this all
the time they take something that sounds
relatively logical well I guess if you
know you'd behave differently no it
doesn't apply to murder now whether you
believe abortion is murder or not that's
fine that's a legitimate discussion we
can have you can't have it with someone
like this because they go with not
murder it's not there's not murder to
procedure well let's discuss what that
procedure is let's discuss when there's
a beating heart let's discuss when
there's a central nervous system let's
discuss when it should occur if you
believe in abortion during the pregnancy
remember it used to be abortion I think
Hillary Clinton spouted this one
abortions should be safe legal and rare
rare now it's abortion on demand at any
time period and we're going to create a
video with little graphics about it as
part of a campaign that really sucks
because there are more videos if you can
believe it I can give you the brown girl
painting her fingernails yeah well we
answered the question purple haired
one-handed black clapping any emojis yet
for purple hair and purple haired
insufferable entitled Millennials
they're yellow people it might as well
be the jobox or branding campaign it's a
bumper sticker
does anyone expect emojis to be
representative of like an accurate
inaccurate depiction of the human form
is that the expectation as much as I've
thought of cat dog as a real animal
smiles emoji used to be smile face
neutral face frowny face and they were
all yellow faces nobody cares about this
is the new frontier for racial equality
emojis that don't exist it's not a real
thing they're in your phone and they're
just shortcuts because that way I don't
have to hit colon circle I don't have
said colon and parenthesis that's why
they exist they don't exist to oppress
you purple haired facial pierced social
justice likely lesbian I assume that's
how you got this job that's usually what
comes with the territory that is the
battlefront for racial equality today
also there aren't enough black people on
The Simpsons next clip it is not your
job to sift through all of my thoughts
and then verify my bisexual status it is
your job to hear me say the sentence I
am a bisexual man and for you to go okay
firstly I don't believe you really I
know you were trying to predict this and
you'll say this response is typical
I think that's an accurate assessment to
make I just here's the thing we'll even
do a Maury Povich I don't know how you
would do the test on air if you can find
me one girl and verifiably prove that
it's not a beard I'll give you the
studio through a garden hose I also love
how this bisexual cute thinks that
removing his shirt is somehow going to
add legitimacy to this video think about
that who's the wardrobe stylist it's
like okay we don't want something that
vibrates on camera into you I'm gonna go
shirtless to prove that I'm not totally
gay and isn't it the social justice
thing here it's your job it's your job
to just take what I say mm-hmm and just
accept it like well hold on a second
what if I what if I'm curious about
bisexuality like how do you go one day
from having sex with a woman to us
what a man's buttocks I'm curious can I
ask a quick no it's your job to say yes
and accept what I tell you that's
exactly what at least up with Reza Aslan
oh people who disagree with me they're
just bigoted and bigotry is impervious
to information or facts here maybe
someone has a legitimate issue to bring
up or a question
no no one really cares if you're if
you're bisexual and when this guy is
announcing I'm bisexual or homosexual as
will likely be the case and within the
coming decade in this gentleman if they
say I'm a homosexual I'm bisexual what
they're really telling you they're not
saying I'm a gay boating enthusiast
they're not saying I'm a big fan of
bisexual soccer they're telling you
their preference of sexual friction this
man is doing it on the outset that's his
handshake that's his introductory
experience to the Planned Parenthood
bisexual that's why people find it
annoying that's why people get
uncomfortable because no one really
cares and no one wants to know that
within the first 5 or 10 minutes of
knowing we can tell that you're gay it's
more like third Damon's here it's more
like third date material which usually
you find out anyway especially if you're
in a third date with Jared people get
uncomfortable with it because people
don't want to immediately know your sex
life it's something personal and
intimate and you know what I know you'll
say straight privilege straight people
don't feel the need to do that
immediately upon meeting you so I just
you know before any of this starts that
I really like having sex with women
straight sex do you really I just need
to know this defines me it's very
important that I have lots of sex
straight sex
my love for vaginas defines me it's
important you know that okay I don't
think you do cuz I heard in your voice
there a little bit of lack of acceptance
maybe maybe some intolerance I need you
to know that this penis loves can't get
enough of exclusively female vagina
and it's your job to understand that
salute March out accept it this penis
vagina all day air day I understand but
can we get on with the job interview hey
if you like this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the Internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lata with credit com /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than six dollars a month
and you get daily content no more clips
Plus this hand at mug
oh I just when I feel it I got a chill
like on the inside